let's just go really quick through some
of the
financial packet we call it a packet
right and in the packet you got your
deck deck's going to tell a story it's
going to be the guide typically 20 Pages
later Stage Company I've seen like 60
page decks you know pre-public companies
uh and then sometimes you have
subcommittees that might have a 20 Page
deck the comp committee the accounting I
was thrown on some accounting committee
before a company was about to go public
and I'm like I don't know anything about
this like that's why we want you there I
just want to back stop and I'm like okay
sure and like I okay I'll go to the
accounting committee to to to you know
ask the dumb questions which actually
was great for me um I was super
qualified to ask the the dumb questions
in that case um but in a startup you get
the 20 Page deck you're going to have
the minutes from the last meeting to
approve uh minutes we have uh
discussions about that with Wilson cini
this week in cups.com Basics that's just
what happened at the last meeting tends
to be one page very high level these
days couple of bullet points then you
have any uh actions you have to take
which typically is giving stock RS but a
big part of the package is the financial
package this is where you get to shine
Scott what should be let's go with our
Steed Stage Company again they raised
three million they're making a million
they got 10 employees what should be in
the financial package yeah and if if I
may i' I'd like to advocate for early in
the presentation you have like the
financial flash page which basically
shows cash
average burn length of Runway and any
kind of like Revenue run rate or
Lighthouse clients you sold something
like that because the reason why I like
to put it early is maybe first page
second page something like that is I
find a lot of Bard board members like
you are used to going to a board meeting
and being surprised by bad news and so
you're kind of sitting there sometimes
like waiting for the shoe to drop and if
if the founder can get that Financial
flash page in front of you and kind of
quell that those fears immediately like
your brain your brain isn't Pro
negatively processing your brain's
positively proc oh great plenty of cash
plenty of Runway or hey shoot this looks
like a problem here not enough cash not
enough Runway we're gonna have to really
focus on dealing with that right so I
like to get it upfront love the
financial snapshot when somebody does
that I think this person knows they're
reading the minds of the board members
who are wondering when are we cash out
when are we cash out are we going to be
able to raise this next round are we
spending too much money is this plan
credible so you're basically saying like
listen hey we always I always like to
use for the financial data the dashboard
of a plane okay you're the pilot you got
a co-pilot in Cruise got a another
co-pilot Navigator wilsonon you got your
crew up there you may have a co-founder
in the cockpit okay what's our altitude
what's our speed how much fuel's in the
in the tanks can we land this plane that
you know are we safe here uh you know
weather report other things are going to
happen but just some basic metrics cash
burn cash balance divided by Burn by
average burn equals months
left we as investors we do this in our
heads all the time okay you're burning
100 a month you got 18 you got 1.8
million in the bank okay you got 18
months of Runway oh wait you have
200,000 in payables okay you got 16
months of Runway oh you got a settlement
oh you got this you know oh 400,000 of
that's a loone from stripe for some you
know against receivables okay what do we
really got right and that this is again
back to bad news back to perception that
you're not being candid just be candid
yeah if you have investors they seen
this movie before you don't need to tell
them that the you know second act is
going to be chaos we know that there's
actually name for it the O Shi t board
meeting every every VC knows that board
that's usually right after you invested
in the company is the oit board meeting
because you get surprised by something
that wasn't disclosed in diligence all
right so we got the financial snapshot
you like putting that up front get your
cash get your burn Runway Revenue
Lighthouse clients yeah a little
snapshot what are the more formal things
that the investors like to see and why
they like to see all three financial
statements and I would put that towards
the back of the presentation because you
got to remember your board is going to
be made up of like a set of people
you're usually going to have like one
super financially person financially
oriented person and you might have one
person who's like super strategic or a
super sales person there's going to be a
mix so put that you might have a product
person you might have a culture person
yeah there different people yeah
different types so you want to kind of
in your general board packet you want to
speak to all those different people at
different times really but the
financially oriented person is going to
know usually it's going to be in the
back and they're going to be looking
through the details and making sure
everything adds up on the balance sheet
and the income statement looks good and
then the other thing is variance if this
is another way of building credibility
with your investors if you show what
your plan said you were going to do and
what your actuals another way of saying
this is budget versus actuals especially
for the quarter last year to date things
like that that's another way of building
credibility take your medicine if you're
if you're above what you said you're
going to spend get in front of that tell
them why explain it maybe the business
is actually kicking butt and decided to
hit the accelerator a little bit
obviously they should probably know that
they should have agreed to that but
that's you really can they will trust
you with their cash and their LP's cash
if they see budget versus actuals every
month because it's just or every quarter
it's so powerful to know how the
company's actually doing versus what
they told you they were going to do and
this is where making a plan separates
Founders who are winging it versus
Founders who are thoughtful you could
wing it like you could could be a jazz
musician no sheet music you're a savant
you just play the guitar you're playing
the drums piano we just all kind of
GrooVe we have a jam session okay that's
great that's groovy but when you're
going to put the album down you're going
to need the Sheep music you're GNA need
the track list you're going to try to do
something more formal so sometimes in
year one yeah you're riffing you're
trying to find product Market fit fine
but once you have product Market fit to
some degree and you got those first 10
customers you're hiring a sales team say
okay we want to add this many customers
okay to add that many customers we need
to have this many meetings and we have
to have this many meetings convert into
second meetings converting into a sale
and then you build a pipeline and then
you have a plan and then you staff the
plan and now okay the whole uh
credibility and the nature of the
startup goes from we're just we're
taking this boat out on little runs
we're going around the bay we're just
trying to see if the boat is good and
how the sales work you know get a feel
for the boat and there like okay now
we're taking the boat to the new world
what's the provisions downstairs and who
do we need to have on here and do we
have lemons because I don't want to get
scurvy out there yes how much fresh
water do we have do we have a flares you
know you want to have a real thoughtful
plan to get to the new world yeah and if
I may it also sets the example for in
your analogy the crew the rest of the
management team is watching how you
communicate with the board oftentimes
they'll come into the board meeting and
present their section maybe the vpa
sales or the vpa product or head of
engineering but them knowing that you
are accountable to the board on
financial matters will help you make
them accountable to you and the rest of
the company there's nothing worse than
like a rogue VP who's spending too much
money or doing weird stuff if you set
the culture on your journey to the new
world and say like look we're going to
eat a certain number of lemons every day
and we're not going to go above that
that really actually permeates the
culture of the startup it's very very
healthy it helps you get to that next
spot yeah and you know also keeps
somebody from going downstairs taking
all the lemons and making a bucket of
lemonade and drinking it on the first
day and you're like no no that's not
what the lemons are for we're supposed
to put like a wedge in every day it's
supposed to be enough wedges for the 20
person
crew